bam huge fan of people recording
i mean it's done it's happening
this is the show power is going to the
mic this time i'm happy
look at that proud of you austin i'm
proud of you how about you mike
i'm learning the rudimentary skills
that's a good stretch mike's got game
dev hair
awesome looks great no no
that's very nice but no i've got i've
got i've got some
major situation going on here i'm so
jealous of that like
classy streak you've got i think this
has come up on the show before but like
that's cool
fantastic it is korean richard's
so cool i gotta i wish that you would
just
shave all this and just leave that as
like a weird silver streak mohawk
well which superstreet mohawk by the way
is a great indie band name
it's localized it's just localized this
is very sp yeah it's a tuft it's
this spot right here funny thing is it's
been there since like my early 20s but
it has expanded
uh so it was like a few gray hairs so
i'm like
dark brown or whatever you would call
the rest of this color everywhere else
um and uh because my dad had the he had
a very
kind of even like salt and pepper it was
very it was
it was you know it was a good mix this
yeah this is this mine mine looks like
the
you know childhood prank of loosening
the salt
pepper the salt shaker top and name you
like do you want some
salt for your soup or whatever you know
like yeah and like
it just all smashed into this one zone
so
i like it we all like it that's been
established we all like it
um as soon as like mike's definitely got
the full peacock going currently has
i'm i'm going mushroom cloud at the
moment yeah because somebody announced a
video game
twice someone did yes who did that on me
it was you oh my gosh and the hair
proves it
yeah the hair is the work that's there
yeah talk a little bit about that on
this episode of playwrights listen
welcome everyone hi i'm alana i'm joined
by awesome with retrobaker and mike
bethel and i also prepared
a background oh yeah you've been great
is it greg miller is it the hologram of
grace
[Music]
that's the kind of that's
that's what they call vertical
integration right there that's beautiful
to be clear mike did not ask for this
okay no i did not ask for that in fact
he explicitly
adam jensen i definitely did not ask for
this no
i like it it's good yeah so uh how's
how's that been what's an outside video
game like
that's a big question let's talk about
it no yeah no it was it's good it was a
it was a weird one it was very strange
in terms of we've not done it with an
indie game
since [ __ ] volume i think like we've
basically
we've either been a situation where we
have a publisher who have been dealing
with that something like john wick
where yes obviously we're involved in
the decision making but ultimately it's
all someone else's responsibility
um the marketing specifically
yeah the announcement yeah like it's not
your you're not dealing with it and then
but then previously like the circular
games were were like
drop them we beyonce those they just
came out um
which was fun this was a big beyonce
kind of
yeah i was like that was it that was
that she did do that you're right i like
that
that's just now the the way we it's a
verb yeah
yeah that was well that was what we were
that's what we always called it like
in-house like when we when i was
pitching the idea to the team of like
let's just not bother with marketing
that was the beyonce was the was the
prototype
um but yeah so it's been good but it's
been
in 2020 it felt like we had to do more
of a build up and a bit more of a hype
so that's what we've uh why is that what
do you mean like
what what what about 2020
puts that qualifier on it do you just
feel there's just more competition for
for more games more competition for sure
i think we well basically to be honest
it was
it was it's mainly because i messaged
someone at valve and was like
so like that thing we do where we like
release
something out of the blue that's okay
still
and like got five paragraphs back it's
like okay maybe it's not maybe maybe it
should be a bit more
considerate but basically yeah well just
just in terms of like
there's more games um everyone's
attention is being pulled in obviously
lots of directions because of
2020 and everything going on um well
that's
partly why i asked because i said when
one says 20 when one
invokes 2020 there's a law yeah it's not
a celebration of the overwhelming number
of great games even though you could
actually
make that a 2020 sub headline oh and
that's a good thing yeah don't get me
wrong that's a really positive thing but
yeah no it just
competing with like yeah a new site i
don't know how many games it is on steam
right now sorry i keep talking overview
i think there's a connection
but like yeah video games releasing in
2020 than normal is what you're saying
it well every year for the last like
three years
five years like steam has been like just
exponentially growing
in terms of the number of games i don't
know what the current stats are but like
in terms of
how many games are coming out every day
yeah it's it's tricky
and there's only so many if you think
about store sorry
i thought the green light program was
supposed to prevent that
you know how i don't know how long ago
that even can self-publish can't you
how did you get approved now i don't
know no now it's just like a
basic i mean i'm assuming that you're
trying to get on steam
mike what's the process for you to do
that i mean for me getting on steam is
is because i'm uh what's that i can't
remember what the name in the system is
but like a legacy developer you're a
fancy you're a fancy developer we've
been because i've
like like when thomas was alone came out
that was that was a time where like you
had your valve contact and that was the
person
you and that person brought the game to
the store and did everything properly
and it was
very bespoke but because there was only
like two games coming out a week back
then
um so because of that like this my
process even that isn't that interesting
though even just the notion of two games
a week even just i mean that's that's
what you almost was alone here
but it's because it was like a lot if
you have like a naive
outlook even that feels like a lot
you know like two games a week and then
it's so funny that
i i think i brought this up before so
forgive the redundancy but i remember
yeah
when banner saga one came out in 2014
they noted that there were 75 games
released
that month on steam and two years later
in 2016 when banner saga 2 came out that
number had reached like 400.
that yeah i mean the same time of year
thousands for sure and i think
the app store is like thousands a day or
something completely
completely bonkers very lazy google
search but it looks like it might be
steam direct
now for people who are not already
established developers on stage
yeah yeah so it's a pretty it's a good
it's a good pipeline yeah green light
died in 2017.
my best yeah green light died but it's
cutting edge there alana yeah
i don't know steam works no it's a it's
a pretty it's like yeah steam direct is
pretty i mean it's direct
it's more akin to what you have on like
the apple store where it's pretty much
basically there's a lot of hoops to jump
through of course and
it's really tricky your first time like
to learn how although that pipeline
works but
ultimately yes anyone can get a game on
steam um and that's a good thing like to
be reiterated
that's a really good thing but it does
make it much more competitive like it
means that
i can't just kind of go yeah i'll just
release a game and people will find it
it's like now if i want that game to be
visible to anyone
uh on the store i have to be the
algorithm and make it so that it's a
game that's kind of perceived as popular
enough uh to justify
the algorithm because that's the thing
with these with with any algorithm on
any store
the goal of the algorithm is not i mean
ultimately the goal of the algorithm is
to make as much money as it can from
every user right like that's the
prevailing it's a business
um and the two ways it does that is it
wants to show you what it thinks you
want to see
and it wants to make as much money from
hits as it can
um and those two hopefully align a lot
of cases so my job as a developer
is to kind of make that algorithm a make
that sure that algorithm
knows that people who like these kind of
games are going to like my game
and b to make sure that my game looks
like a game that people like
and therefore it should be served to
more players um because
it so so the way you do that is you
essentially just make it so your page
gets lots of attention and lots of
traffic
and lots of wish lists and all this kind
of stuff and that feeds the algorithm
kind of the information that this is a
good game that people are enjoying
and then from those people who are
interacting with it it can go okay so
which people are enjoying this
oh it's people who already own this game
this thing this game this game
so therefore i should suggest this game
to people who like those games
yeah and it's kind of so you're you're
trying to look like a hit but also
you're then
as a as an additional thing to that
you're trying to create aware of the
algorithm know
who yeah it goes so awareness it puts
you on store because ultimately there
are only if you look at like the steam
store any store you go on
there's only so many slots right there's
only so many places you can see a video
game on any of these stores
um on steam it's fully algorithmic with
a
with some exceptions like in terms of
those like full page takeovers
um with other stores they literally sell
those spaces
because they're so valuable you know so
it's it's uh so what's your what's your
take
on wishlists as a
as a steam specifically as a kind of
market force because i i see a lot of
people how many times have i mentioned
wishlists on twitter in the last 24
hours
tweeted about it it was like you're
really good greg greg's been
awesome greg has been like super super
supportive i mean you know you're
kind of celebrating the game and so he's
been great he's a wrestler of a human
he's very good at
being a hype man he's he's yeah no it's
personally it's awesome
he does yeah i actually like i've i yeah
we don't tend to talk about dms although
i genuinely messed him like dude
thank you but like you don't have to do
all the stuff
as well yeah yeah yeah no it's great
it's really cool
um mike's game
greg sorry greg miller is in the game
yes which is called solitaire conspiracy
just listed now no it's um
so wishlists are important for a couple
of reasons so wish lists
one they're just a metric of success so
you're telling the platform holder
hey people like this game and are
waiting for this game
um they're also though so that's just
that's the obvious one that's the one
everyone would presume
because the average conversion rate is
this is one of those moments where i'm
wondering if this is ndaid information
there is a conversion rate that
developers know
i'm not sure if i i can't remember the
number back end i don't know
quantum mechanics of game design like
yeah those are really predictable
there's a really predictable number i
mean i would get a number of wishbones
i've had another 2070 2017 on my
wish list for maybe like
seven years and i still get emails every
time it's on sale but still haven't
bought it
so but it's higher than you think it is
higher than you think it is interesting
yeah it's it's it's
like people are predicting i mean this
is the this is the weird thing with any
kind of
once you get into statistics this is
where it gets weird always right is you
realize
how boringly predictable we all are
ultimately in those like buying stuff
um so there is no there is a number and
it's known like among the developers i
just can't remember if it's like an
nda portion of the valve backend but do
you do traffic
do you like do you trade off of that
then like
you kind of use to broker a deal like
with someone about something like hey we
have
we have ten thousand we have ex wish
list so therefore yeah there are 100
publishers who would want that
information i've i i've never done it
because i've never
announced a game before going to a
publisher by no other indie developers
who 100 it's a metric
basically any success metric you can
share is
is something you can kind of tell you
know we have this many uh troy's
mentioned on the show before like
pre-orders are triple a currency like if
you know
what your pre-orders are looking like
and if those pre-orders looking good
then it changes everything in the
triple-a space in terms of what
promotions you can get what store
support you can get
a million different things but with the
wishlist the other thing with it the
other two things
one is what alana just said of like
alana's
basically thinking about anno 27 7
once every couple of months because
she's getting the email she's not
clicking on it she's not buying it
that's cool
statistically there are lots of people
who are
responding to that email you know she's
she's the normal per
she's she's the um she's not the outlier
she's the standard
but there's enough outliers who will buy
it that it's it's great
um so there's that so cynically anyone
who wishes my game gets marketed
over and over again which is really
great i got the data
uh this is on a games industry.biz
article um but the data is provided by
valve themselves so it says
steam wishlist actions of all wishes
made prior to release
13 of them will be converted during
first week of release meaning
sales 13 uh that's not bad another 13
will be within 12 months another 3
will be after 12 months 27 removed from
wish list and 44
will just leave it on their wish list
which is already 20 77 a lot of parts of
the world
by those numbers that's what 25 are
acted on uh eventually
nineteen percent of all wish list ads
convert to sales within 12 months
um and 20 after that yeah
so so that's significant like it's not
the majority but it's significant
than a lot of other engagement metrics
like if i if i if i
you know uh if i put out a tweet
that says hey i just released a new
album
it's like you look at the metrics and
it's always you know
this tweet had ten thousand impressions
like it it flew across this many
uh feeds of that ten percent at most
you know like it and then of that you
know
five percent actually clicked the link
and then of that
one percent bought the album it's like
it's just this
so there is the same cut off right so i
still have to get you to wishlist it and
i know the numbers so i know the numbers
for yesterday of how many people mike
mike
i did not i i i want to do it live while
i wrote one
do it now do it now i'm getting i'm good
i know the stats though of yesterday so
we
when we're recording this we we
announced it just over 24 hours ago i
know the stats of like
how many people i know how many people
kind of went to the page
uh roughly i know how many people wish
listed so there is still
there's a big drop off as you'd expect
between those two numbers um
but crucially this is this is my point
about
about kind of you know convincing the
algorithm of the game's kind of
popularity
is all those numbers along the way make
matter those breadcrumbs
everything you do when you click on that
link that's a metric
like of people who've clicked that link
when you go to steam and you search for
the game
that's a metric because you've heard
about it on a website and you make a
little mental note to go and check it
out that's a metric
every time you interact and that's and
that's crucial that's we've already seen
that there's one
this is so this is deeply cynical but
like
you you guys could now if you go onto
steam and do a search on the top bar for
solitaire
we're the top answer for the problem of
solitaire on the steam store right now
because we did so well yesterday i'm
gonna test it there's plenty of
solitaire games on steam
we're the most we're the best answer to
the question of solitaire right now
you're the most you're the most greg
millery version of we're the
we're the most the most miller tastic
can i
austin just quickly what's interesting
about that is a that's a cool thing and
that's useful for us and that helps us
serve
but anyone who wants to check if i'm
still correct when this podcast comes
out or when you guys search it
by searching for solitaire and getting
that result and clicking on it
you're reinforcing to the algorithm that
that's what you want
and that's and that is in itself helpful
that's the correct way that's how you
choose
loops exactly right it's all the same
stuff you're doing in terms of
running a successful youtube channel
you're just feeding the algorithm the
data it needs to consider you enough of
a success
then it makes you success the problem
with youtube is it changes so much sorry
go ahead austin
no no please i feel like you were trying
to say something for a while there
i'm cute yeah i do it no we want to hear
it
well two things first off just as a
general observation when i opened up my
uh steam home page based on
recommendations of our
illustrious audience i played
spirit fairer uh i have many thoughts on
that game
um very mixed uh thoughts on that game
but
funny enough greeting me just this is
totally unrelated to what you're talking
about but it just is hilarious to me
that it goes because you played spirit
fairer
may we recommend portal 2 which
is also funny because i already own that
so i feel like steam is still
refining here's what's interesting if i
type solitaire
like as i type s-o-l-t-a
okay s-o-l-i-t
the solitaire conspiracy i keep going
a i r still you as soon as i put the e
you vanish and it says regency solitaire
shinzen solitaire jewel match solitaire
fairy solitaire
so the incorrect my users click early
but that's interesting right because
probably that's actually and it shows
how
i mean these algorithms are not super
smart they're efficient and they get the
job done
but like probably what that's telling
you is the word solitaire being searched
in full
historically for the last house old
people looking for real solitaire
has been has been those games right and
but the people who've gone on the
website in the last 24 hours
it's collectively typing solitaire until
they see
our game and click that's why that's
being served so
it's really good for us it's still good
right the whole world are trying to
browse which of the various solitaire
games they want to buy the people who
just and people have been doing that
behavior
for 10 years forever
in my mind they all look like george's
parents on seinfeld it's jerry stiller
and and
what's her name those are the people
typing solitaire hit enter
carefully perusing the options they are
not interested in
greg miller greg miller yeah
all right thank you for spotting the
command and conquer of it all by the way
i appreciate that
that comparison well ironically that was
also on the homepage commander conquer
remastered uh
held my attention before i googled
solitaire and almost made me forget
about you completely because
midweek madness has the remastered
collection of command and conquer on
sale 25
off i'm just saying there you go but yes
you have now been
officially wishlisted by my profile so
go on
i'll just i'll just check the screen oh
yep let's go on that one there it is
click plus one quick plus one it says
austin wintry
intent to buy xero that's what it says
yeah it says this
this user seems to think they'll get a
key sent to them on release there
they're not going to buy it that's
awesome it's really it's an amazing
system in fairness in fairness i have
every expectation of being sent a
key before release day you will get know
that you will 100 percent i feel like
i feel like that's not an interesting
horrible
thing once it once it's ready for press
of course
can i get a patch where troy does a vo
replacement of greg's
so troy we have greg's body
but it's troy's voice which saints row
was it where
it was it wasn't was it was it were you
in the saints row troy where it was an
option was that
you were well you could like select you
on the menu right no no no no it was
nolan
you could just nolan um yeah what's the
difference i was
i would but you were in a saints row
i know as i was both so so saints were
the third
and then saints row four which
is a funny story because saints row four
was actually supposed to be dlc
and so they pitched this like crazy
concept
like what if we just said [ __ ] it and we
did aliens and it was
all of this stuff and then they were
like well that sounds like a thq
was you know this is the last gasping
breath of thq
so like what if we just double down on
it and we just make uh
make it an actual standalone they're
like oh no no no you shouldn't do that
at all
and so it it kind of shipped in a weird
in a weird state but
one of the things oh safespro 4 is
awesome
it is just off the rails banana
bat [ __ ] crazy um and it felt to me like
the spiritual successor of like vice
uh uh vice city like gta because it had
like this
isn't that the whole point of that
franchise to to like
be the the bat [ __ ] response to yeah
well before like saints row one and two
were trying to be like
the answer to it they were the um
the battlefield you know if we're going
to be the call of duty killer and so
they were like we're going to be you
like gta
we're more hardcore and then saints row
the third they got in new writers and
they were like
how about we just become our own thing
and we take the piss and just like make
this a complete and
almost parody of it we we are the you
know
uh uh were saints row one and two more
earnest
yeah yeah they were grounded i never
played those so it makes me realize that
i just assumed they were always nuts
musical theater it becomes more silly as
it goes through the wrong yeah they
they were not as grounded as gta but way
way more grounded and i think saints row
three i'm pretty sure it was three
it's one of my favorite video game
trailers ever it was kanye west
power and it's someone it's it's like a
nightclub or
the very least a party and there's
almost like these slow-mo effects like
such a good trailer
saints row the third and introduced the
uh
dubstep cannon which yeah yeah
which was a gun you could fire people
that made it the same
way you could turn into a toilet i
remember that was there was one
that was in four years saints row the
four um
the dubstep cannon is so uh key and peel
and they actually made one yeah dubstep
cannon was great and then there also was
one of the first weapons you got was a
giant purple dildo
that you could beat people with now that
was iconic that was
more iconic than anything in watch dogs
that was an iconic weapon that was good
you know my
my uh my selfishly my intro to that
whole world was on i think it was it's
five right that's the gat out of hell
um yeah it's technically just four dlc
isn't it
yeah yeah they've been doing this get
out of hell
yeah you're right music right and there
was the musical
that was that was my that was my uh that
wasn't even thq that was like
the volition went on to go with like
somebody else it was deep silver
was deep silva you're right because i
got the call from deep silver
uh for that because they said they said
we're trying to figure out how to make a
very disney
style musical for saints row and alan
menken
needs like yeah we need we need someone
who knows their way around that vibe are
you interested in helping and
so that was funny because i got i didn't
even know travis
uh at the time and i got this vocals of
him performing
like they basically scratched out a
melody had him sing it and had the other
cast sing but there was no
track behind it it was just like voices
in a vacuum basically
and they were like can you can we make
this into like a super disney style
musical of of uh jezebel uh singing to
her father satan to let her out because
she wants to like go on dates and stuff
and
uh and it was freaking just
one of the weirdest best yeah i was like
i love i i
am so happy to be doing like this
old-fashioned
alan mankin disney musical number of
like satan and his daughter
i need some water johnny cat it's really
funny it was
i didn't know what it was they were it
wasn't entirely clear it ended up being
i think the kind of announcement
trailer for got out of hell um but it
was awesome we recorded that with the
brussels
philharmonic orchestra uh so it's like a
big
giant 80 piece like full-on it was so
and it was like what is this game like
i've heard i in my mind
i didn't realize how batshit those were
because i just it was one of those that
had been off my radar somehow and
is it on steam it makes you want to go
back and play it you know what's on
steam you can wishlist it
it's actually a seventh onsen you're in
um
a musical video game or involved in it
in some way
um correct me no
troy i believe that's been announced it
has oh austin you are too
you both i'm like writing the music and
stuff
well i guess when i first got the credit
honestly you should talk to austin about
this dude
you're directing troy as well right
personal friend
yeah the game is some of all games and
it's called chorus
and adventure musical and i i guess it
lists
in collaboration with austin wintry troy
baker and starring laura bailey
well the the title is still whip so
we're still
we're still workshopping titles but
right now plus
also there was this game that was
announced called
chorus um like it was like a space sim
game uh that that yeah that's the one
where the u looks like a v
it's next-gen yes yes yeah they so they
they they announced next-gen you
yeah it's been so our our our creative
director leah messler and the head of
the company and
it has just been like he's he's the
beautiful stage i'm sure mike you
understand this that beautiful stage of
dove where it's just like [ __ ]
just a head against desk or wall
exhaustion it's just like come on
because we were we had this great
momentum going into
that hair uh going into 2020
and then and then all of a sudden 2020
and then it's just like
man oh okay what are what are we
supposed to do here
so it's just been this constant running
the gauntlet
of uh being an indie studio and
producing a game that
you're doing so far without a publisher
and it's exactly what
we let off talking about it's it's it's
this navigating this new space not only
of being a
an indie dev functioning without the
necessity
really even of a publisher but also
without the support
that comes along with that in the in the
the the current environment of trying to
ship a game
under quarantine especially because most
of the developers are in
melbourne which is in like not just
quarantine but it's like children of men
down there
isolated and quarantined currently has
the
strictest lockdown in the entire world
crazy
props to australia for taking that stuff
very seriously but it is also
really brutal like and it should be
noted that they did that
in response because they opened up
because they had
two cases a day they were recording two
cases a day and then they opened
up and they went from two to twelve to a
hundred like
it it multiplied exponentially and then
they shut it back down
um so yeah they uh but it's still it's
hilarious though because the
it's all relative like their peak
numbers were laughably low one percent
of la county you know i mean it was like
it was it was it was
it was oddly enough an incredibly
conservative
city like it's it's it's not like this
wildly liberal
city it's like melbourne melbourne's pr
isn't it like the san francisco of
i'm it's pretty [ __ ] gay
but talking to the this is what i found
interesting is that talking to lisa
we're making a musical there i suppose
we're just stereo excuse me excuse me
sir are you straight we're making it
musical
please please um we'll be authentic
um but from from hearing from liam he
was like it still
is rooted very much in conservatism
which is part of the problem
of i guess he lives there i would
say so the most conservative part of
australia is
uh sort of the outskirts of sydney and
even then it's still a very small amount
so it's it's possible that it's
melbourne is absolutely majority liberal
but it is entirely possible that it's
like
but there's still more conservatives
than you would expect interesting
it's not a one-to-one conversion of even
what that means because
my understanding and this is where alana
i trust you to correct my inaccuracies
with vigor uh i
uh free speech laws are really not the
same there
uh i saw a viral yeah okay
that that that that matches with what
what does that mean
well i saw a video that went viral a
friend of mine shared of
a woman who was fed up with the lockdown
in victoria i assume in melbourne
who said she wrote on facebook
i want to organize a protest against
mask regulations
against curfew like kind of like we see
in the u.s like [ __ ] this this is
ridiculous
and police showed up to her house and
arrested her from the facebook post
uh and she was screaming
she's screaming in the video her husband
is like filming from his cell phone the
whole time and she's screaming i'll take
it down i'll take it down
and they're like and i i got the
impression that the cops were not like
[ __ ] you they was kind of like we have
to do this like this
you know this isn't on our this isn't
our judgment call in this book it's just
like the reminders
yeah so i was gonna say we want to
remind you this is the same
country that spawned mad max it's like
every once while they
they pop their head up and like we'll go
crazy
no i mean oh man very heavily
policed uh the state that i'm from they
call the nanny state because we have so
many laws
um but it's also just like this is super
anecdotal but
i've never been pulled over or even
spoken to a police officer since moving
to the u.s
whereas in australia it was very
frequent like i'd be pulled over maybe
like once every three months
just in fairness driving a mad max car
with flaming
i sort of i sort of it was technically
had some illegal modifications but
that's besides the point
i just feel like i really see cops here
like you can't you know drink
in public you can't smoke in public i
remember when i moved to san francisco
and technically those things were
illegal at the time but everyone just
did them anyway
so yeah australia is very heavily
policed no free speech laws there are
certainly still
healthy amounts of protests and they're
very frequent and the police won't
police will escort you if you tell them
we're protesting here they'll literally
you know barricade the streets and help
you
protest for any reason um but we don't
we don't have anything
to protect i really want to test that
theory
okay they'll let you protest for
anything
i think so yeah i mean if they if
they're is that just common practice
because because here it's it's enshrined
in law like
the right to protest right together
constitutional constitutional
guarantee um freedom of assembly freedom
of speech
yeah so it's like if if it's one of
those where it's heavily policed but the
but they will let you do it is it just
one of those is it like a brodude cop
thing of like
as long as we're cool with you we'll let
you do it but we don't actually have a
legal obligation to let you do this at
all
at any moment we can take your ass to
jail i don't i don't
know um but i mean you know there's
still anything there's
many a protest and police are on board
and it's you know they can be for
either political alignment so it's like
they're they're sensitive to it and try
to be careful about it like i've seen
that's where i'm just curious is that
police have still been helping is it
like
i think i think america tends to because
america has such a specific kind of
well no i guess such a broad kind of
approach to free speech
yeah most countries in the world don't
have free speech laws i think
it might be the only one i think exactly
and i think there's a
we were probably an assumption that you
can't protest without free speech laws
it's not necessarily true no you
absolutely can't a lot of countries have
we we have
i've mike isn't there isn't there
something you guys do every year or
or something there's like a recurring
thing where basically the prime minister
sits on the hot seat
and and people just basically hurl
insults like you can say whatever
it's like an open forum hot seat i
remember like tony blair had to do this
it was this was
prime ministers do you mean prime
minister's questions is that what it is
that's every week
where they go in our house of parliament
and they will
and the other mps can ask any questions
they want
so i thought it was more just like it
was it was the intent of it was to
berate it was like
you're doing a [ __ ] that's just how we
do it no it's it's
there's a thing he's the guy that i love
who's the guy that's at the house of
commons i can't remember his name but
he's not the prime minister but he's uh
obviously
um but he is ah he's almost become like
he's a meme
he's so like that guy
yes yes it is oh what's his name
everybody's typing the thing well he's
no longer there he he retired right
right but he was like the antithetical
to mitch mcconnell but anyway
um well i mean he is basically there to
lead
and organize the house that's that's how
he that's his job is basically
to bring order to the house yeah he did
it with such
like panache and pizzazz it was so great
what they have to do because of
up on parliament crazy because it's
people
but the thing that that we have freedom
of speech funny though
like how rowdy if you watch c-span
our our procedural kind of
government in action seems far more
stereotypically british
whereas like insofar as you have
politeness there's a decorum that is
you have an unhealthy based upon
parliamentary law
you know i understand respect for
politicians i agree i agree
i agree there's a new there's an
interesting i don't know if i agree with
this i'm uh
i'm a and i need to say this very
carefully i'm a lower case r republican
in that i'm not
pro uh the idea of kings and queens i
don't like the i
like the idea of you believe in a
republic not a city i believe in a
republic i am not an american
kind of government do you have what is
the other
we have we technically don't
constitutional right okay
well we don't yeah that's we're we're a
constitutional monarchy
yeah so we're we're the same i mean
ultimately and we share no we're not a
constitutional monarchy
at the wii was australian australia she
means australia i was like
i saw hamilton i know how it went down
no it's um no it's uh it's yeah we we
don't technically have a democracy we
have a
essentially a dictatorship i mean my
point is
yeah the thing that i think is a really
interesting point is um
there's an argument that the reason the
british have such rowdy government
is because we have a head of state who's
not elected
who we can you know for student honor on
and love on and the queen is great we'll
put her on stamps and we all love the
queen that's not
the case at all but that's a national
there's a national pride in a figure
whereas in america you have to tie your
identity much more
to to a leader who is a politician in
that moment
it's the idea of like if we have kind of
this
ultimately technically politically
absolutely incapable person
who we say is the leader but doesn't
actually wield
much power except for in a figurative
which is too much in my opinion but a
figurative power
so we can do that and we can hold that
person
as a special person or whatever but then
we have zero
uh respect for our prime ministers
because we don't need to because they'll
be gone in a few years like so
there's a healthy level of disrespect
disposable mentality there's a
disposability to our
politicians which i think is healthier
what's to go back to the freedom of
speech thing though specifically within
the within our country
that that only extends so far because
what you can't do
is in any way make a passive or
tacit threat against the president
isn't there always against the president
okay you will have secret service
show up to your house and arrest you
if you can't threaten anyone can you
sure
you can threaten whoever you want well
there's a difference it's not true
no no there's a fine line there i've
been i can say about that awesome i'm
going to kick your ass
that's that there's there's nothing you
can't say you can't say and
you can't go into the public square and
say i'm going to murder austin wintry
without expecting something yeah right
yes
the difference is which argument is what
that australian woman organizing a
masterless protest was doing
well yeah i i get why they would have
arrested her is that she
yes breaking the rules region
[Music]
but if you announce that you're going to
commit a crime that's different that's
the same thing as like i'm going to go
rob a bank a cop is going to come talk
to you
but if i in any way imply any threat
whatsoever towards a
united states president and i'm being
very very careful about how i say this
because i remember on dallas radio
one of the djs of because dallas is like
number three
i mean sometimes it goes back and forth
but it was between number three and
number five market in the entire country
so it's a large market
and morning drive time host um
at that point george bush was the
he was a candidate i don't think he even
think he was a president then
he made a joke about
i i think it was a kennedy joke he's
like well if he's coming through dallas
wasn't he just swing through dealie
plaza or something like that
wow secret service showed up
yeah and he was off the air and had to
like do
like he was like yo guys i was just
kidding and they had to literally
take that out of the tape and it was it
was a big deal it's the one thing that
gets you the death penalty in the uk
is is treason that's the one on the
books it's not been
it's not been utilized i think for like
how what would constitute treason
like a verbal
but you can say that you're gonna that
you're gonna do that but you can't
actually
do it i wouldn't try it i wouldn't try
it
i would i think i wouldn't try it but no
almost all over the screen for those who
are not watching
coffee almost all of my brother's screen
so just that was the most brightest i've
heard this for a long time
i wouldn't try it i wouldn't
try it one
as a as an obvious non constitutional
lawyer but as someone who is fascinated
by this and watching
a healthy amount of i know i hate to
break he could be if he wanted to be
couldn't they
yeah you've been charging me though
you promised me go ahead
i'm sorry that's um
i um i think
explicit calls to violence
are where the line is most easily drawn
so if you try to rally people to
you know like go
attack uh someone or go rob a bank or
whatever
citing a riot is against the law that's
what i'm saying that is that does
constitute that's why when people talk
about
do you have hate speech laws as well
presumably like yeah again we
do but that's that's always a
contentious that's an extremely
fraught subject because the definition
of hate speech is
basically completely unclear it's flawed
because we're human but you know what
else has kings and queens
solitary solitary i was gonna do it so
terrible you beat me too and i was like
it's it's almost like it's a
it's one person it's almost like there's
a conspiracy it's like
basically what i'm saying is greg miller
2020. basically
wishlist solitaire conspiracy yeah uh
actually i can i ask a question that was
i'm putting that i'm taking that audio
clip of troy
and using it without permission on the
next trailer that's very good
uh one one uh thing that when we were
kind of
offline chatting a bit about this but
something that i genuinely don't know
the answer to that
i've always heard a little bit of
reference to as my fly on the wall and
various games that i've been part of
is mike yeah he's adjusting he's tuning
me out i think
uh i am he's like i'm getting some
static on the line
um the queen's just walked in so i have
to do whatever she says
i wouldn't have had to do that for what
it's worth so don't be jealous no you
wouldn't you you you
your forefathers died i watched your
show that's right we fought a war
yeah i love
um especially in my case since
every single one of my ancestors were
here long after the revolutionary war
like like i have absolutely no american
heritage that goes as far back to the
founding of this country so the idea of
like
we showed you damn brits um
anyway so i the question that i was
asked is um
uh the i think actually it was alana
that you kind of floated this as a as
a thing to think about that i realized i
don't really know the answer to is when
picking
a release date and also the window
between announcement and release
you kind of got into that a little bit
with the whole beyonce ing thing but
like
there's all these conceptions or there's
these broad notions that like oh you
don't want to release in this window
because that's when all the triple a's
are coming out and you don't want to
release at christmas because you're
competing with this and
it's like is is that is that true or is
that just one of those kind of things
that
because it seems like there's such a
steady supply of things
all the time that there being genuine
kind of blackout windows
uh might be a kind of
aphorism that isn't actually supported
by data can you just wisen me a little
here on this
front no i think i think it's a weird
one because the problem with reality
problem with reality is you can't a b
test it so you can never go
right okay would our game have sold
twice as well if we'd released it a week
later because you only ever
do it once right especially with our
side of things with like
you know i used to work on like facebook
games back in the day those you could a
b test because you could like
secretly release two versions of the
games to different markets or whatever
and you can really
test this stuff but no basically it does
seem like
that stuff is worth considering in terms
of release schedule so
the big one is um is is
interest from the audience an
opportunity to sell to them so interest
from the audience is
like when have people got money in their
pockets generally people have money in
their pockets
um in the summer um they don't tend to
have as much money in their pockets
towards christmas uh because they're
buying gifts for people
and traveling and doing whatever um
and also they don't tend to have money
for like two or three weeks after
they've spent it on someone else's game
so that's that's
important to kind of try and avoid those
moments maybe
but the other one i think the very last
point would only apply
to very specific like you're not going
to wonder yeah yeah like you're three
games a year so like
yeah cyberpunk is one there's a reason
every game is
stepping back from cyberpunk massively
because everyone assumes that if
that's gonna get bought the the other
one though and i think possibly the more
important one is
is the opportunity to to find that
audience the kind of that
you're looking for that space where no
one else is
you want to be the only game in town and
that's obviously impossible in the as
you because of all the games coming out
but you want to be as close to that as
you can be and i think that often trumps
everything else so we've always kind of
tried to be really clever with when we
release games when we announce games
so that we are avoiding other people's
stuff we're always we're always trying
to find that gap where
because there's there's always going to
be these weeks and they do pop up every
now and again throughout the year where
you're like
nothing's coming out you know or you've
you know there's only 700 games this
week
yeah but even if it's but even if that's
not true right there are those weeks
where it feels like a quiet week right
there's people there's four people who
are massively engaged with like
games news and game releases and stuff
there are those moments those patches
where nothing's coming out the other
thing is where nothing's coming out
maybe on your system
you know switch was really interesting
at launch because switch had nothing
so indies a lot of indies did enormously
well for like the first
three or four years on the switch yeah
even re-releases because anything was
selling on switch and then of course
what happened was
everyone went well switch games sell
really well so we all flooded switch
and then that did less well after that
so the people the people who were there
first did really well
we had similar with pc i've always said
like basically
one of our ongoing tactics is to pay
attention to what
um ea declares dead as a general rule
if ea says single-player games are dead
by god we're going to go and make a
single-player game if ea says that like
multiplayer is dead we're going to make
them all because what happens with
yeah specifically well honestly i'm
using them as example but like any
triple a company
the ea often do it ea will often kind of
declare something is
is not the future because the aaa
companies tend to move
with each other this happened thomas was
alone you can track
the wave of indy the kind of those first
wave indies of like um
super meat boy binding of isaac came
later but yeah
the and then thomas was going a little
bit later and still
those those bastian that era of indy
absolutely
and when where it did very well those
games all did very well on pc
coincides with all of aaa giving up on
pc
pc is dead was the cliche for like a
couple years
so they all left they went to console
and they left this massively fertile
ground but there were still all these
players who wanted games
but now there wasn't the big aaa
releases so those first few kind of
pioneering
uh devs and this this is a cycle that's
happened many times he's one of the
first indies but there was
that group of indies who brought those
games out did well we saw the same thing
on switch
the best bit of advice i always i try
and give indies who are starting out is
find somewhere where nobody is either
because there's not enough games or
also genres like going we look at what
what games are out and which which which
genres are popular um and which games
are selling within those genres like
solitude it was
like it was the summer
he was like we have decided that
solitaire is dead
yeah all the all the data to an extent
we did actually you know
saying you're making a joke but we did
it we literally i started playing with i
was making like
i was so solid second seriously
literally started because i was just i
was like i've never made a card game i'm
just going to start prototyping a card
game well here i can prove to you
i can prove you solitaire did die this
year because you know the only time
i ever play solitaire is on [ __ ]
planes
and uh and so that's i'm probably not
alone so probably there was a giant drop
off in people's
solitaire consumption but genuinely we
did look at that genre sorry just one
second
we did look at our genre and we did see
there are solitaire games and some
really good solitaire games um
jake burkett mate of mine makes some
really good ones including regency
solitaire um
which we mentioned earlier like there
are these really good solitaire games
but we definitely look to that space and
when these are kind of
maybe aiming at more of an older
audience maybe leaning more in a lot of
cases fantasy
and kind of going in that direction
there's nothing
kind of if you're a sci-fi nerd right
there's no sci-fi
solitaire no that sounds like it seems
like there's there seems like there's
enough players on
you know if you look out how successful
sci-fi strategy games are on steam
there seems like there's a niche here
that's not being sir and that's what we
saw yesterday when we announced was we
saw lots of people
like getting into it and saying why is
this not already been done and that's
that's the reaction you always want is
like that there's a there's a
this is an um this is a this is fertile
ground for a game
so we can come out and we can jump into
that space and and do something
interesting
um is the plan is there would you say
then by and large that you're saying to
people who the advice you would give to
people in the indie space is to go
somewhere where no one has gone before
is it almost like prospecting because it
almost feels like real estate you want
to
you know either build on land that has
yet to be developed or you want to find
kind of that
real estate kind of moves in that five
to seven year cycles like i understand
that this doesn't look like a good
opportunity right now but if you look
down the road this thing's going to turn
over so get in now
so is it for for any developers is it
like look you're you're not going to be
able to compete in the first person
shooter space so don't make a first
person shooter you're not going to be
able to compete in the third person
action adventure so don't really do that
what you want to do is what previously
was a proven
genre that has since been abandoned
or can you be so cutting edge that no
one has ever done this before
is that this was called that was being
different
sorry well i was just saying just
quickly that that what you just
described one of those two
was essentially jack atrich's thesis for
erica like
and i think and his his conclusion was
miller's the one that can also bring it
back
and obviously sam uh sam barlow sent me
a message yesterday like
mike i'm like no i'm not doing it i'm
not going for you it's all good
we're all good um no the it's also
marketing i think this
fez i think is such a good example of
when you're in indy
you have to be able to share the concept
of what your game is
as quickly and succinctly as possible um
and it should be visible what it is and
how you play it
in a screenshot in a tweet and i think
that that's that's
the fez is such a good example of that
that a large part of the success of fez
was that you could watch two minutes of
gameplay and understand entirely what
that game was
a single assignment i mean you've never
played it before i want to know what
mike has to say
because i was i was curious from just
like an indie game it was his quote that
i was questioning
so what what would you say you were
saying that was your advice
yeah oh the thing yeah the way to go
so i think i think i think yes to what
you're saying but like there's
definitely no wrong answer like it's not
don't do this it's more just try and
find that
weird space basically try and find the
opportunity where no one is
or the other one that really seems to
work and this one's harder to spot
is where someone's recently really
messed it up so i don't want to
lay into ea twice in one episode but
like
um sim city right and then city skylines
and the way that played out there was a
simcity game uh
people love simcity the game came out it
had loads of problems i don't know if
you guys remember this
network production ai problems yeah did
not function
not not ready yeah and city skylines
came in
and when there's sim city and that's
i mean i think the developers would be
the first to say like with the first
version of city skylines that was all it
was like it was
it was it was sim city done well and
they came out i think a few months after
the sim city that was not was not fit
for purpose but that also means that
they
absolutely took over but that also means
they got lucky
like they got really lucky yeah you know
there was no planning involved there it
wasn't like
in terms of a game in two months you
know whatever yeah which is
they still didn't have years and
millions of dollars they still made
choices around launch and if that's the
question of kind of when do you release
your game and how do you release your
game
they 100 would have been so they
probably my assumption would be that
they knew simcity was coming out
they as a development team went okay we
can't we wouldn't release the same week
as simcity
so we'll we'll make our development and
we're going to come out months later and
then when simcity came out and had all
those problems
i bet that dev team and their publisher
looked at what was happening with
simcity and went okay we are now
whether we like it or not the reaction
to this how do we frame ourselves and
how do we put
so they probably made choices in terms
of their marketing in terms of how they
brought the game out
to actively not to no one wants to like
knock another developer really that's
not professional it's not the right way
to be
so they weren't putting out trailers
saying simcity sucks but they absolutely
would have been going okay so the things
people don't like about simcity
if we're doing them well let's talk
about those things and discuss and they
they kind of fill that space but i think
yeah it's what alana says it's it's
being unique
and standing out is obviously massively
important being direct
you know the reason the game is called
the solitaire conspiracy
is so that there's not much ambiguity of
what the game actually is like we know
with that genre
with our audience we're not going to
call it
the predicament of you know one of my
pretentious game names we're not going
to call it that
solitaire circular surface conspiracy
you have to get it
exactly you have to get it did you say
that you gave simcity a zero
yeah and then reviewed it so on launch i
gave it a zero
because it literally didn't function you
couldn't do anything some of the menus
even crashed it was
unplayable fun fact anno 2077 in case
you didn't know
also a city building game it's still on
my wish list
you'll get your statistically you're
likely to buy it eventually
hey i'm talking about it now so yeah
maybe exactly
um
um for anyone who doesn't know danny
o'dwyer who left gamespot started that
uh
there's a youtube channel document
series documentary series about video
games and i made one for dream daddy
which sure had the backing of being
associated with the game grumps
but also that title
with the art and then also they had a
like short version that was like
dating dads something something
something like it just they just made it
so
social media marketable that you see
again one screenshot and you know
exactly what it is 100
you know the vibe like the the art style
it just
it was talking to them about it that was
like a big part of their strategy was
and i guess that's especially coming
from
content creation side it was largely led
by vernon shaw who's done production for
game grumps for a long time
comes from how do we make sure we can
market this thing as quickly as possible
on social media and then a game kind of
evolves from there rather than the other
way around and i think that's the
biggest thing like of all of the indies
that i've spoken to
um is make sure if you want me to notice
your game as press
that i understand what it is immediately
try not to say zelda like or dark souls
like because
everyone does that you can't give me an
email that's like this game is like dark
souls because i will always be like sure
they all are what else can you give me
about it so i i understand marketing
indies is
is really hard but i think the the
biggest has always been
we notice things that change the pattern
as you know when you're walking through
a store
you're not going to notice the item
that's been there the whole time
you're going to notice the thing that's
noteworthy and attention-seeking and
different
or just clearly it's our job like
literally just the key art that's behind
alana we specifically
sat down and went okay we literally were
just scrolling through steam and going
what do solitaire games generally like
and what do what do other games
and we noticed oh no one's doing that
kind of super brightened
uh vivid color look in that space so if
we do that art style
it will probably catch your eye as
you're scrolling through
do you have these conversations
everything is just about attention
seeking and getting that getting that
spotted
one of us feel that that the i'm sorry
so go ahead it's just a little comment
that one of my when you were talking
about don't say dark souls
and blah blah one of my favorite
examples of this was working with andy
schatz on monaco where he
uh on um uh well actually he's had two
really good ones because monaco he kept
saying it's hitman
meets pac-man uh which was a great
way to kind of explain the game in a
sentence
uh and then again on his art on his rts
that we did called tooth and tail
um he said um i want to be i think the
way he described it was this is the
mario kart
it's mario kart meets starcraft um
because the idea was it's mario kart is
not gta right or not uh gran turismo
like
mario kart is meant to be instantly
understandable and playable
and you can get really good at it but
you can also suck and have a good time
and and but starcraft the rts genre in
general is considered high barrier to
entry
so he was like i want to make an rts
that you just you can sit down and play
and you don't have to
understand you have to be this hardcore
competitive esports player blah blah
like you just and so to me that
mario kart of uh uh
like mario kart meets starcraft was a
was a freaking awesome way
to say it's this plus this but it's
actually neither of those things
and that's a whole lot and that's the
challenge that's the really difficult
thing
from like from like a consumer facing so
i think that's great among developers
i've always struggled with that approach
when talking to the players
because the problem i think i think the
way developers think about games is
fundamentally different in that we're
thinking about the systems underneath
the surface whereas i think
players are thinking about the game
they've played which is utterly fair
enough
so i've run into trouble before because
and this one when we have a subsurface
circular is
the problem the biggest problem we have
is subsurface circular one the reasons
we ended up doing
um the beyonce release was a screenshot
of subsurface circular
looks like one scene from a much bigger
rpg like it looks like a dialogue system
within a bigger game
so we knew that if we compared it
because essentially
subsurface circular is hey you remember
that really fun dialogue driven mission
in mass effect
we made a game of that we could never
say that in press
because the second you invoke mass
effect
there's a million other systems brought
all this baggage to the table
people think of rpg people think of of
crew
and multiple characters and blah blah
blah blah blah mining foreign [ __ ]
resources scanning probes
that's that was what was missing from
subsurface and even in your analogy what
mario kart means to every individual
who's playing maracai is going to be
different like what they think you mean
when you invoke mario kart
is going to be different and that's so
it's always risky to do the comparison
we stopped doing it because we were just
like this is just causing us way too
many problems
well and that's to be fair you present
you're just incomparable
but that's that's that's that's what it
is by this same token we're not like
other games
would you not say that by the same token
like being the person
i always knew this was the same thing
like with music someone ever go
yo what does your band sound like you're
like i don't know man we're just a
really new song like [ __ ] off what do
you sound like like like
i want to know give me some framework is
because we're all emulating our own
um we all stand on the shoulders of
giants
like you're inspired by something right
even if that was like
being able to look at a genre in a space
and going no one's occupying this
current space i bet we can do something
really cool here
so i'm going to put my own aesthetic and
my own life experiences and view
that new this new project with that so i
don't think to be able to go is like
this is like dark souls
is necessarily a bad thing it's like
zelda i think that you have to be able
to
i always appreciate someone going okay
what if you did this
but you did this with it like to me it's
like okay now i'm instantly in the same
you have found a way to make that
relatable and resonant with me well
that's where the information rich
like aspect of promoting a game in 2020
comes in is like
that's what your trailer's doing that's
what your copy is doing
yeah i love games that i like dark souls
and like zelda
like i love that the issue is i hear
what you're saying is
they keep saying the same [ __ ] but the
trailer can convey that like with
dark souls the one that i love is is i
feel like the easiest way
any game and you see the aaa games
they've kind of taken some things from
dark souls have all done this in their
trailers
the easiest way for you to convey to the
player who likes dark souls
that this game might be for them is to
put a camera lock on the character and
like the little white dot on the enemy
the kind of that indicator that happens
and with the and with the camera
rotating right i've seen that trick done
in every successful
aaa kind of trailer for that genre of
game because that just subliminally
alana's watching that and she goes oh
dark souls i get that
and so you don't say this
well no you can kind of you can hint and
you can kind of pull those
those references and i think that's
better because at least that's
more direct it's not hey this is like
dark souls which could mean a hundred
different things
it's showing that so you do choose what
you show you do choose oh we
you know with um with the trailer again
i'm sorry i keep coming back come back
to this game because this is what i've
been thinking about for the last two
months but like with the trailer for
solitaire conspiracy
it deliberately starts with the most
literally in the notes for the trailer
when we were putting it together
it said show boring solitaire for about
10 seconds and start the trailer kind of
starts off with this kind of very slow
pace
this is solitaire like you know what it
is because we need everyone in the
audience
to remember solitaire and how it's kind
of boring and what it
is and then on top of that we then show
all the stuff we've done on top so
here's the question but you still
choose to signal that information if i
just said it's like solitaire from
windows 95
again means a million different things
for different people but i can show you
the bits of my game
that will rub that bit of your brain
that remembers how much he likes that
other thing
oh genius well so here's a question
here's a question about that then
because the the devil's advocacy sorry
troy did you just say so genius after
speaking because i liked that you can
put that on the box yeah
that's yeah this is great i learned i
learned so much
and it's it's it's um it's one of the
things i love about these conversations
that i'm able to like go oh never
thought about it in that way and
certain things i've always kind of just
taken for granted they just kind of
happen you're like no there's always
there's always in some way there's code
behind everything that that happens
and you better believe that like the
average kind of aaa trailer has like
10 times the consideration i'm talking
about right like we're we're just
chumps making this in our in our living
rooms like this
the big stuff has teams so was apple
computers man that [ __ ] was made in a
garage
marketing is literally manipulation so
it is it is trying to figure out how to
get people to think about it
yeah that's true actually um sorry
austin you were going to ask a question
yeah just we'll just quickly the the the
kind of devil's advocate to the way
you're describing we want to start off
with boring solitaire is do you
also then think are we
like for the hearthstone player that
would see that
and instantly reject our game because of
that but might otherwise like it
see i made that comparison just looking
at that i was like okay i got i
understand this is gonna this is gonna
appeal to the hearthstone players
that's what i thought when i saw the
trailer so this is where it gets
interesting
it's in the modern algorithmically
driven thing
if you're the player who sees and i say
boring solitaire hopefully everyone who
goes and sees trailers and see it's very
good
i'm showing it on the screen right now
okay very attractive so
that that section i'm calling boring
solitaire that kind of five to ten
seconds at the start where it's just
showing a regular solitaire game
if you're someone who sees that and goes
let me go back to that bit
that's not for me i don't want you on
the page
because from the moment you decide not
to buy this game
you become risky to me because you are
someone
well a first of all because they might
hate it and go start talking [ __ ] about
you
so let me let's i feel like i'm just
spewing secrets after secrets
subsurface circular right i was gonna
say tell me i'm ready to release my own
solitaire yeah
so subsurface circular if you go to this
if people go to the steam page for that
again all of this is helping my metrics
so thank you very much anyone who
actually does this
if you go to the steam page for solo for
subsurface circular
subsurface circular's copy is actively
trying to dissuade you from buying the
game
every single line in that is saying
trust me it's not for you
like it's it's saying it's a text
adventure it's very short
it's this it's that we are we are
basically
self-deprecating to the extent where
we're actively trying to get rid
of any player who's not going to be into
that and now it's a conscious decision
because
one of the most bad things for
developers is negative steam reviews
because those are very visible on the
store right if
a game's got a bad a bad ratio on that
review column on the right right it
shows up to the player very quickly
i think most users myself included
that's the first thing oh yeah if a game
says even if a game says
mostly positive you're like this is
rubbish
i'm immediately like there are there are
enough people that hate it
that it will drag so how do i solve that
and if you look at subsurface circuit i
think it has like a 96 percent approval
rating in that category please no one go
and be mean about it
that that it's you know fine
we actively want the player who's not
going to enjoy the game
we made to never buy it right because
once they buy it and they're
disappointed by it
that's just negativity is that specific
that's going to get us bad reviews
and that is that an indie strategy
because i feel that's a that's
definitely an else strategy that's not
something right
we're very lucky in that we get enough
eyeballs that we can be selective about
audience in that way yeah yeah but
it's going to be honest i think it's
better for everyone i would rather i
don't know i don't want to
sell someone a game they don't enjoy i'd
much rather if you're not someone who's
not who's if you're someone who's not
going to enjoy my game i want
i don't want your money i want you to go
and spend your money on other indie
games
i mean every i think everybody would i
think everybody feels that way in some
uh also you i don't want your metrics i
don't want you to be leaving
so i can get i i should i should i will
shake your hand and
ask you to come back and play the next
game if you like it like it's a
respectful thing
but it's also like you know it's it's in
my best interest to be honest
which is good that's actually a good
that's a good thing about steam is
as it is a system that incentivizes me
as a developer to
correctly sell my game to you which is
very interesting i really thought about
that that way i mean i've always it's
funny because i have given the exact
advice
that you're describing when like
composers earlier in their career
or if i'm giving a talk to a bunch of
composers like gdc
um and there's always that kind of if
you had one piece of advice just a
single takeaway for someone who's just
getting rolling
i always essentially say what you just
said which is
i encourage you to be divisive and
announce
very unapologetically this is who i am
so that a would-be
developer a would-be filmmaker a
would-be producer
uh collaborator can know immediately
really certainly i i will not get along
with that person i am not interested in
hiring them or
i [ __ ] love that person and and leave
as little middle ground as possible for
you to be like
this milk toast name that ends up on a
list but then we found someone else so
we'll you know
maybe call you next like the more you
can really unabashedly be
you you you will push people away but
you will also draw people in
and if your whole fear is just i just
don't want to avoid pushing people away
you're never going to draw people in
that you have to be willing to accept
both
it's a risky play though right it's a
risky play like a risky player and
that's something i need to say in the
context of like how we sell games
but i want to be really clear because
all the stuff i'm saying is like from a
position of like
i have a couple of very successful games
i have lots of people from the press who
follow me on twitter like i have
i have a level of access that allows me
to pull off these things yeah i just
want to be really honest with the
with any indies but how does it how does
this is not necessarily directly
applicable what you should take
is the intent but somebody doesn't have
what you have
everything you just those those those
privileges that you have earned i'll add
that that that no there's no question
that you what you just said is true like
people follow you the press knows about
you
there are players who've played all your
games uh uh
like but that said
i wouldn't say that the the answer to
mike bithell circa 2010 is
everything i'm saying about taking risk
only applies to mike bithell 22. no no
what might you should
still be should still be we should be
risky but what you should what what
mike from 2010 should be taking from if
he was watching this
which maybe explains how he is okay like
maybe he is
maybe this is what's the episode of
voyager where someone like steals a
computer from huge aim
it's uh it's anyway um but like it's
it should be it's the intent so i have
opportunities because of
how my games have done and because the
press likes me or whatever
but like the intention behind what i'm
saying is the stuff that i think is
learnable and teachable which is find
somewhere people aren't
find opportunities that other people
aren't taking advantage of
um try and or basically honesty is
always the best policy in terms of
selling anything to anyone
in terms of long term it's definitely a
very good policy to what if you want to
have a career and stick around and not
burn bridges
honesty is the way to go i think those
things are useful and learnable
but yes the manner in which i follow
those intents is
is yes the doors are closed on some of
that stuff to other people but i think
that's
the that's the trick and i see i just
basically this is reactive to i see a
lot of indies who are like
i did this thing everyone should do this
thing and then we'll all be millionaires
it's like no that's not
that's not how this industry works yeah
if i may
i feel like there's a difference between
being risky and being cavalier
so you are i think you always have to be
risky and no one who
you can't lose what you don't put in the
middle right so you or you can't gain
what you don't put in the middle
so the the notion of is like i i
remember the first job that i ever had
and i think i've talked about this
before the um the actor that i was
talking to
i i said at what point in your career do
you stop because
you're implying that at some point you
will have arrived you will make it you
never will if you believe in something
you ask
for it from the very beginning and
because
you just better make sure that it's
something that you really believe in and
i think that's what you're talking about
it's yes you have had success and that
has garnered you some other things which
which allows your risk factor from to
move from here
now to here but you're never going to be
cavalier that's going to put
especially knowing you you're never
going to put your studio or your
employees
at risk due to your being risky or being
you're being cavalier you're never going
to put that no the risk scales
yeah the the risk-taking scale so for
example that's another great thing about
this thing we do where we have these
shorts which is the circular games and
this
and then we have what we call like our
main games which are like john wick and
other stuff
like there's definitely can't wait for
other stuff too by the way others
other stuff is one of my favorites i
will wishlist it's my best game
if you type in other stuff on steam it's
like the third thing that comes in
other
the reason the shorts can be so risky is
because they're very like
bluntly they're cheap like we make them
quickly so
solitaire is like five months
development cycle so and with
uh only kind of three core full-time
team members on it me
the artist and the composer so it's kind
of there's there's these
yeah we we take risks with the stuff we
can afford to take we can be off on
guard on that one
yes and then with the with the stuff
where you know
10 jobs are on the line that's where
we're a bit more careful for the record
for the record studio right if you
search other stuff on steam
you get literally zero results so i'm
just saying go where there's no one
you can give us and give us a solid you
can give us when a lot of starts to raid
us
yeah i've been i've been like growing up
like sort of a text
work meeting this whole time
the brilliance of what's been going on
with this ted price picture
what what's this it's it's just lucy
james started it
and then like tamora has picked up on it
rahul has picked up on it
it's just it's just it's just awesome
it's just shut up but i was also just
gonna say everyone yeah
we'll keep in touch with mike uh
throughout who's mike
mike bethel throughout this process of
physical games
we just love solitaire conspiracy that i
can wish list right now on steam
you should wish list it right now i will
i really by the way can i ask troy has
people who wish this for him
are you are you going to keep it
exclusive to steam are you going to move
it out to
uh it's not an epic too right it's on
epic as well
um so i've been really cool second sorry
ios ipad so i mean bluntly honestly it's
always a case of with these shorts
because we try and keep the cost down so
we can take the risks we always go pc
first and then go from their base so
with the circulars they did really well
so they ended up on switch and on ios as
well if this does well
then yeah we'll probably explore those
but like we have to know
we have to i need to see good reviews
and i need to see like
the sales to justify what's going on way
to passive aggressively talk to the
audience
i need to see some good reviews in place
and then i just really that's the same
thing like i really wanted
like i keep pushing jack attracts like
can you please put
erica up on ios and he was like
sure do you want to pay for it i mean
for one totally
ironically it was originally for that
they were going to be ios
that was where i first played it right i
feel like i played a prototype on a
iphone years back you did yeah that me
too
and then and then the deal with sony was
subsequent and they had to reverse
engineer
not reverse they had to re-engineer
their tech to work on
playstation and then because the
entirety of development happened in that
tech
to get it on ios it has to then be
re-re-engineered
you can't just go back to the pre-sony
because they learned
they learned so hard especially with
those guys as well because that's a lot
of very bespoke tech they built for that
like
i'm lucky that i use unity so like
porting is hard and expensive but it's
not as high as expensive as i imagine
their product i i suspect also one of
the biggest challenges with erica
porting to mobile is that
erica is basically 40 trillion quicktime
videos
[Music]
um
the file the file size for ios like it's
just hard to crunch a game like that
down to mobile because it's literally
movie it's hd
movie files like you can compress the
[ __ ] out of stuff but how long is
it it's a feature length it's there's so
there's about
it's about a two-hour game but there's
like something like over five hours
worth of footage because
the branching is just out of control
well that's the club
in the game like you will not hear
certain cues that austin where he was
the composer of that game
it's true a separate very fascinating
conversation but holy [ __ ] i'm being
heckled by work and i have to go
it's yeah we've been very indulgent uh
like two guys in the muppets going i
wouldn't listen to her podcast
pretty much yeah i have other stuff to
do too and mike
bethel has a game too mike has a haircut
so
i have to get a lot of chinese language
strings into the game right there there
you go
austin nothing at all you just play
piano hang out
yeah with this trophy that he has up
there i think
that's some reason that's a uh that's a
um
further away pants are confirmed by that
i got a uh
pants are confirmed i did that just that
was that was a tr that was a david
blaine
really different podcast although
although if you look carefully you can
see
will you please go buy a new pair of
shoes by the way are those still those
are nudes
no no i do i finally finally i reached a
situation where the holes were it was
more holes than shoes he was like
my feet feel very liquidy right now and
it's like that's blood
oh well yeah that was separate the the
lining wore off so much
the light that no i for like two weeks
straight every pair of socks had blood
stains on the heel because uh
the plastic was just jutting out so
severely and
troy was like i think it's time to bust
it's awesome look what can i say it's
too long
here's the point here wait wait he's
taking it it's totally a pair of socks
here's what
here's my defense i wear shoes
like nine minutes a day because i put
them on to drive to the studio and i
immediately take them off and then i put
them again
on again at night so i'm like what's
faster ride your bike by the way or you
used to walk
to i did used to walk to the st i didn't
have a car for a year and a half i
walked to i walked to the studio about a
40 minute walk it would not have
would not have lasted more than a day
and that's probably what accelerated the
death of those shoes
to the ankle bleeding state they were in
i love ending on this note this is just
a perfect way to round out
so here's here's a much better i want to
give everybody a splinter update
splinter is doing quite well we've been
feeding him almonds every day oh yeah i
forgot about that
mike was not prepared for the emotional
investment as i recall yes
no no i couldn't i'm i'm i'm feeling
comfortable getting involved
splinter is good yeah i think it's great
to send you okay
go get by work bye everyone